quel bilan follement des pourparlers
entre la russie et les etats unis les
négociateurs des deux pays se sont
retrouvés hier à genève pour parler
crise ukrainienne et sécurité en europe
il en sera à nouveau question demain
lors d'une réunion otan russie à
bruxelles je la correspondance à moscou
de maylis d'estrées
le kremlin se montre prudent à l'issue
de ces négociations qui n'ont abouti à
aucun accord au sujet de l'ukraine et du
nain élargissement de l'otan exigé par
moscou et ce malgré les plus de sept
heures de discussions
pour le moment nous ne voyons aucune
vraie raison d'être optimiste lorsqu'il
hérite d'une évaluation positive et
cette évaluation positive a été donné
par eric of sur la façon dont ces
négociations se sont déroulées
je veux dire leur caractère c'est à dire
qu'elles ont été ouvertes substantielle
et direct mais ce n'est pas un processus
pour le processus et ce n'est pas
quelque chose qui peut donner
satisfaction car c'est le résultat qui
est important ici il n'y a rien à dire
sur le résultat tu vois il
y aura encore plusieurs séances de
négociations qui nous permettront
d'avoir une meilleure compréhension une
image plus claire du point où nous en
sommes avec les américains pour le
moment malheureusement il est impossible
de tirer des conclusions je suis assez
choqué
malgré l'absence de résultats washington
prend très au sérieux d'après la
diplomatie russe les demandes de moscou
pour garantir sa sécurité face à l'otan
la représentante américaine wendy
sherman a toutefois déclaré que la
politique des portes aux odeurs de
l'alliance atlantique se poursuivraient
en ce qui concerne l'ukraine la russie a
répété aux états unis n'avoir aucune
intention d'attaquer son voisin une
hypothèse véhiculée par moscou kiev et
leurs alliés en raison de déplacements
de troupes russes le long de la
frontière russo ukrainienne
pasqua a toutefois prévenu que
washington ne devait pas sous-estimer le
risque d'une confrontation d'après les
etats-unis la russie n'a pas apporté de
réponse à leur demande de désescalade
si la situation n'est pas désespérée
pour reprendre les propos de la
diplomatie russe l'absence d'avancées
sur le sujet de la non extension de
l'otan et du non déploiement de missiles
près de la russie risque de compromettre
les futurs cycle de négociations avec
les états unis un processus qui pour la
diplomatie russe ne doit pas prendre des
mois des années